the second trailer for ghostbusters
afterlife is finally here and there's a
ton for fans to unpack in this glimpse
of the latest ghostbusters story
here's some of the details only true
fans noticed in the latest ghostbusters
afterlife trailer
in the trailer a black and white photo
of the four original ghostbusters as
shown
they're posing in front of their
firehouse this photo appears to have
been taken on the sets of the first
movie
based on the clothing they're wearing it
was probably taken on the day that the
ghostbusters were visited by the
spiteful epa inspector
walter peck he winds up shutting down
the containment unit holding all the
ghosts they've captured
causing an explosion that frees all the
trapped vapors entities and slimers
as hundreds of spirits escape and begin
creating mayhem all over new york city
the ghostbusters are arrested
ghostbusters afterlife will focus
largely on characters who are new to the
franchise
but the latest ghostbusters afterlife
trailer includes two appearances from
some familiar characters
the trailer's first cameo comes courtesy
of annie putts
who can be seen reprising her
ghostbusters role as janine melnitz
the former ghostbusters receptionist
appears to be giving carrie coon's cali
a tour of the creepy farmhouse
left to her and her children by her late
father egon spangler
janine someone with your qualifications
would have no trouble finding a
top-flight job
in either the food service or
housekeeping industries
pods doesn't appear again throughout the
rest of the trailer but her appearance
acts as an efficient way to connect
afterlife to the original
two ghostbusters films the familiar
manner in which janine refers to aegon
also suggests that janine could possibly
be the mother of coon's cali
which could potentially make her egon's
wife and partner janine and egon did
share a romantic spark in the first
ghostbusters film
but pott's character went on to date
lewis tully in ghostbusters 2.
still it's possible after life will
reveal that janine and egon ended up
getting together some time after the
events
of ghostbusters 2. or janine could just
be giving cali a tour of the farmhouse
as an old family friend
either way the scene is a fun nod to the
connection that janine and egon had in
the first ghostbusters
the ghostbusters afterlife trailer
appears to give us a few hints as to
what evil is at the center of the film
when phoebe is over the edge of what
appears to be some kind of volcano-like
portal an
arm suddenly reaches out sharp-eyed fans
may notice that the figure's electricity
laid in arm and spiky hair
is reminiscent of goza the extremely
powerful supernatural being who was
introduced in the original ghostbusters
movie
in the first ghostbusters goza takes the
form of the stay-puft marshmallow man
and wreaks havoc on new york city before
being blasted to smithereens by the
ghostbusters
goza also had two loyal subjects who are
central to the ghostbusters
universe vince clautho the key master
and zul the gatekeeper
if gozer does in fact return for
ghostbusters afterlife
it's possible that its minions will
return too the afterlife trailer is
partly framed by a conversation between
kelly and mr gruberson over dinner as
the single mother explains the dynamics
she has with her children
she gets some fine with her son trevor
but she has a fraught relationship with
her daughter
phoebe it's not clear whether callie and
mr gruberson are on a date or not but it
wouldn't be surprising if their roles
were a bit bigger
than the trailers have implied so far
the 1984 film established that two
entities are needed to free gozer
the gatekeeper and the key master zul
possesses dana barrett in the original
while vince clotho takes over lewis
tully with gozer seemingly threatening
somerville in ghostbusters afterlife
the malevolent entity will likely need
two hosts to open the gateway once again
since kali and gruberson have struck up
some kind of rapport it's possible that
the sequel is setting them up to be the
new gatekeeper and keymaster
officially known as terror dogs in the
original film ghostbusters iconic
monsters look like giant horrifying dogs
with horns and demonic glowing eyes
the terror dogs were used by gozer to
possess dana barrett and louis tully
turning them into its servants now it
seems the terror dogs are back to
recover consumerville
in the trailer we see a dog break
through the doors of a walmart and chase
a frightened mr gruberson
through the parking lot we don't know if
this dog is zul or vince clotho
or an entirely new creature either way
it's clear this terror dog isn't likely
to play nice
nice doggy cute little pooch
maybe i got a milk bone
clearly ghostbusters afterlife is
leaning into the mythology of the first
movie through the apparent returns of
both goza and the pterodacts
when egon explains the history of goza
and its worshippers he says that evo
shandor a master cult of nearly a
thousand followers
in the 1920s they conducted rituals up
on the roof
bizarre rituals intended to bring about
the end of the world
now it seems like evo may have had a
backup plan in somerville oklahoma
in the ghostbusters afterlife trailer
the mines on the edge of town are called
the chandor mines
the trailer briefly shows trevor and his
friends exploring the mines which are
filled with ominous statues and occult
imagery
then we see a huge cosmic portal
swirling overhead
releasing a horde of ghosts into the
small town perhaps evo shandor himself
is responsible for building the mines or
maybe one of his followers decided to
have a backup plan in place in case
their rituals didn't work
perhaps the biggest surprise of the
ghostbusters afterlife trailer
comes in the last few seconds after we
see an old commercial for the
ghostbusters playing on youtube we see a
phone ring and dan aykroyd's raymond
stance picks up
we only see his arms but we instantly
know it's rey because of his voice when
he
we're answers it looks like the former
ghostbuster is still running as a cult
bookstore as evidenced by a neon sign
for the shop on the window
ray first opened the shop when the
ghostbusters will serve the judicial
restraining order between the first and
second movies
and fans will definitely be excited to
see him back in the franchise
raise a call seven o'clock in weekdays
midnight and saturdays
thank you if you look closely at rey's
arm you'll see a tattoo that's actually
a reference to the conversation he had
with winston zedmore in the original
film
but they talked about a bible verse
depicting the end of the world and how
it tied into their work
maybe the reason we've been so busy
lately is because the dead have been
rising from the grave
how about a little music check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss
a single one